i love this film i thought it was such
an
interesting fascinating watch uh can you
talk me through
how someone decides to turn their life
into a documentary
well i um i got two stents put in my
heart
and when i came out of it i was talking
to my wife
about wrestling a lot i had thought
about it quite a bit
and she was like what what what are you
talking about she didn't really
understand it
but it had been something that had been
sitting with me for a long time the sort
of
way people had been bullying me and just
kind of
being the you know joke of
the business so i wanted to stand up for
myself and
and sort of give myself a voice through
the process i learned that it really was
about
loving myself so no matter what anybody
says it just doesn't affect you
don't take it personally but if you're
beating yourself up
you tend to read things that are
negative
and believe them that's what starts
triggering you and like getting you
really
pissed off so that's what i
learned i mean if you i think everyone
should make a documentary on themselves
i think personally like i'm the champion
of my world but you're the champion of
yours and i think that's more of an
attitude that we all need to have
that's awesome that's downright
inspirational
when you re-watch this documentary or
like when you watched cuts in the
process did you come away
feeling net inspired or did it kind of
re-trigger
or re-scratch those scars or itches
yeah it definitely re-scratched and
opened up all these old wounds
at one point my wife who's the main
producer on it and did such an
incredible job
producing this film she uh kicked me out
of the editing room
i was no longer allowed to be there but
it was a really good lesson for me to
sort of relinquish control not you know
allow
incredible filmmakers like david dark
and james price to do what they do
and uh work with parallax of
incredible uh editing group so
uh i was just you know i i knew i wanted
to be
incredibly vulnerable and open and just
really let everyone
see into my world um so i
knew they had footage like that they had
the stuff to find
you know the story within it but me
being sort of nitpicky about
in the edit but don't use that or to use
this just
was slowing the process down yeah
is there anything particularly intense
or interesting that
wound up leaving on the cutting room
floor that you kind of miss
well there's a ton of stuff there's a
ton of stuff me and rj city did a whole
tag team run within the independent
circle that there's some pictures and
stuff
but it definitely didn't cover it to the
extent
that there's a lot of really interesting
stuff there um
yeah there were a lot of stuff i got to
wrestle honky tonk man and that's not in
it
you know there's really some really fun
cool stuff that i wish
were in it but uh also you know you only
have a
you know certain amount of time to do a
film without
you know making it multiple episodes or
something
for sure the love and the reverence for
the sport of professional wrestling is
so strong throughout this thing
um what is one of the first matches you
ever
remember watching that kind of like
inspired you or turned that switch on
i really loved uh i saw andre the giant
and hulk hogan during their whole
feud and it was just a house show so no
like
you know no uh
belts were exchanged i don't think he
was able to body slam him it was a big
build up to that um but
that really had a profound effect on me
seeing him in person
and just going to the shows i always
loved miss elizabeth so she had a she
had a really
close place in my heart
just as like a kid like you know
seeing this beautiful woman and i
thought she was so sweet and kind
so uh and i thought i always thought
macho man never treated her right
but you know that's him playing a heel
in a great way
and the same with rowdy rowdy roddy
piper
he uh he was really one of the best
heels and just
an inspiration on uh
in the ring but also more so as a person
outside of the ring i got to
have a dinner with him that i'll never
forget
that's incredible uh we kind of
see you transition through the film i
think in the wrestling matches near the
beginning of it you're kind of
it looked to me like you were forced
into playing a heel
and then by the end you're kind of more
of a face or a hero of the match
is there a role you prefer playing or
that's more fun for you
yeah i'm definitely more of a baby phase
than a heel
yeah it's really hard for me to be mean
to people
you know i know now how to stand up for
myself if someone's trying to bully me
or push me around
but um yeah it's hard for me to be a
heel and do
heel stuff like at one point i turned
heel
uh mainly because i i wanted jerry the
king lawler to put me back in my place
so i i just wanted to do the same move
that he had done on andy
kaufman a pile driver so uh
we set this thing up where i'd lost the
match
and i got really upset and i said you
guys never believed in me
you know and then jerry comes out and
tries to talk some sense into me i said
don't come near me jerry i'll sue you
i'll sue you and then he comes and he
pile drives me and
put my head back on straight because i
wasn't thinking straight
but as i was getting out of the ring
there was one kid in the audience who
was probably about eight
or something and he was sitting there
and he's crying and he's saying
i believed in you i believed in you
and i was like you know like i was about
to like start tearing up i was like
i did i didn't want to break the
you know business but i didn't really
know what to say either so
i said oh i'm
it sorry off that is heartbreaking
it really was i think about that kid all
the time i
hope i run into him sometime it could
say sorry kid i was just
wasn't thinking straight there is
a a huge reverence for a kind of shared
reality of the experience of
professional wrestling
but there's also this wonderful sequence
in the film
where we kind of watch you choreograph
a match and i'm curious it felt like
there were three people you the other
wrestler and a choreographer
what is that process like is there room
to kind of push back
on a move someone wants to make what is
that like well it was
nick uh the referee and yuma the
producer that were the other two in
there
and it was me and rj and that's
essentially a
a rundown of what you're gonna do right
before you you go out
like it's sort of what you do with the
producer
the booker segment producer kind of
thing
so i cleared it with yuma and nick that
it was all right to show this
sort of behind the scene element and uh
rj had a lot to do with sort of that
with the with the editing room and
and helping construct that
and so once we got the clearance from
them
i'd heard it had been done before on
film so it wasn't like i was the first
one and sort of disrespecting the
business
i also wanted people to see how
how it is choreographed but it's still
real you know it's still
um you know it's a lot goes into it
you're not just doing moves necessarily
you're telling a story
and we wanted to share that with people
it was fun watching you kind of light up
even at the moments where your character
is losing so to speak
yeah yeah it's totally i mean there's a
lot of people that that's one thing i
still don't get like
people say like i'm not gonna do the job
for him
like they won't won't want to play along
because
of either their ego or and i get it now
i mean there's like
this value of your
persona and character that you have to
be respectful of and understand and not
put yourself
in things that wouldn't be true to your
character
so that but a lot of sometimes in the
wrestling business
people think we call it they live the
gimmick
which they start believing the fact that
they're either
indestructible or uh whatever
i i know for a fact i am not immortal
it's something that i thank god have a
grasp on because
you can get yourself in a lot of trouble
if you start believing
yeah that goes for acting too a lot of
actors like it
start believing this whole crazy world
we're in
and start seeing themselves like you
know
better than others which i just never
subscribe to any of that i just think
you know i'm the greatest in my world
and you're the greatest in yours
and as long as we can all figure that
out i think we'll
stop disrespecting each other so much i
love that
speaking of so many facets of wrestling
being real there's that really
hard to watch match that put you in the
hospital
where there was a knife put at you your
your throat got cut
was any of that pre-planned was that all
a surprise for you
and also if you could walk me through
the moment when you decided to walk back
into the ring and finish that match
like most of wrestling like it's
choreographed to an
extent but sometimes things go
out of control you know sometimes
different egos are involved and uh
i do have to admit that me pulling his
legs is what cut my neck
and that was on me because i wasn't
supposed to pull his legs so the main
lesson i learned in that was always
stick to the plan
even if things are going wrong but there
are a lot of
elements there's a lot of nuance to that
match
a lot of things that were that i did
wrong a lot of things that he did wrong
but uh we were all really fired up
it was really uh there was an energy in
that
room and in that on that night that was
really
kind of dark but also really exciting
it was a total experience it's kind of
what i did this whole thing for i
go into the ring with these
fans hating me because that's sort of
that world is really hardcore
and then we were able to flip it so that
they really were cheering at the end and
that's
that's like that's a the whole
goal in uh wrestling is to engage stuff
and
the fans in the story that you're
telling for those few minutes however
many they are and really get them
invested and believing
and worried and happy and
angry and if you can start to having
them go through this range of emotions
you're doing your job and in the perfect
way like you get a huge
pop at the end and then the match ends
and then there's a big celebration of
that
you know if the good guy wins then
someone
uh that the good guy wins uh
that's usually what i'm hopeful for but
if the bad guy wins someone should come
out and
you know teach him a lesson that's sort
of like the heels should never
truly win it shouldn't because be
because they're
smarter stronger they should
you know heels are are chickens you know
they're
they they don't have they will they'll
do anything to
cheat and win
yeah there's a lot of that going on now
i don't know what you mean
um shifting gears just for the final
moments here
i am really excited to hear that you are
rejoining
scream five because i'm sure a lot of
folks are
uh i'm curious if there's anything
particularly exciting or surprising
about this latest installment you want
to share
well courtney's cox signed up so we're
really excited about that
we're waiting to see if nev sides on we
have tremendous filmmakers involved in
it and kevin williamson's given in his
blessing
as has the wes craven family
uh estate so i really am excited about
carrying on his sort of
his legacy just you know uh
bringing all these people back together
on a project that he started that
uh people love so much so to continue to
let those characters be seen is really
exciting
and being part of i love playing the
role of dewey so i'll be fun to
grow this mustache back are there any
kind of
new wrinkles to dewey that we can expect
or that you're excited to play
i have no idea i mean i can't even i
don't have no idea what they're gonna do
so that's awesome um final question for
you
what does the future look like balance
wise acting versus wrestling
for wrestling it's pretty much i mean i
did it for this
movie for this experience i hope
it probably will mostly live there it is
something that once you're a part of it
you're kind of always a part of it
so uh i don't know none of the real
bigger
companies want anything to do with me at
this point so
i'm not sure i do love the independent
circuit
and would love to travel with rj and do
some tag
stuff if that was to happen i'm not
really interested in wrestling alone
because it's not as fun for me and it's
not as entertaining
me and rj have a really fun deal we do
but i still have to get him on a talk
show and none of the talk shows wanted
me on this cycle either
so there's still all this stuff that is
like
you know well that's within this movie
that still exists you know until like
the movie maybe does
really well then oh suddenly aew
or wwe will be interested or something
you know what i mean but it's such like
this this game
you know so mainly what i'm trying to do
is just sort of focus on the stuff i
want to do
that's what i'll kind of do next but if
it were to
wrestle or something that could be
interesting i just kind of
i don't know if i'm up for it anymore
it's so painful
we can see that in full detail thanks so
much for your time it was so great
chatting with you
thank you greg appreciate it